♪♪
>> WE'RE NOT BACK DOWN.
WE HAD A BAD DEAL WITH MEXICO
AND CANADA CALLED AND A HALF FAN
I DON'T THINK SO.
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE A TRADE WAR.
>> I UNDERSTAND IF WE GET, IF
WE GET A GREAT NAFTA AGREEMENT
AND AMBASSADOR IS TRYING TO DO
THAT, THAT WOULD BE A GREAT
THING FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME, 25
PERCENT OF STEEL AND THEN
ALUMINUM, FIRM LINE IN THE SAND.
>> NOBODY WINS A TRADE WAR
ESPECIALLY IN THESE DAYS THE
UNITED STATES WHEN WE'RE SO
DEPENDENT ON GOODS COMING IN AND
GOING OUT FOR OUR
COMPETITIVENESS.
>> THE VOICES ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM THERE ON THE IDEA OF
THE NEW TARIFFS.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
MIKE.
WELCOME.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS TODAY,
THERE'S NO WAY WE'RE BACKING
DOWN.
YET THERE'S PUSH BACK DOMESTIC
YET THERE'S PUSH BACK DOMESTI
DOMESTICALLY.
DO YOU THINK HE MODERATES IN
THIS ANY WAY.
>> IT IS TRUMP AND WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT HE'LL DO OR THE PEOPLE
AROUND HIM.
HE MIGHT.
A LITTLE BIT.
THIS IS A CAMPAIGN PROMISE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT TRUMP
TALKED ABOUT FOR DECADES.
AMERICA GETTING RIPPED OFF AND
NEEDING TO HAVE THE KIND OF GOOD
DEALS PUT IN PLACE AND HAVE FAIR
TRADE.
I THINK BY AND LARGE HE LOOKS
LIKE HE WON'T BACK OFF.
I EXPECT HE WON'T.
HE MAY MODERATE ON THE MARGINS,
THE NUMBERS.
THIS IS A FIRST REAL BREAK HE'S
HAD WITH WITH HIS PARTIES ON
ECONOMIC ISSUES.
PAUL RYAN COMING OUT AND -- AND
BASICALLY BLASTING THIS.
NO SUPPORT IN HIS PARTY FOR
THIS.
I DON'T THINK THAT MATTERS TO
HIM.
I THINK HE'LL PUSH FORWARD.
>> HE'S TALKED ABOUT IT FOR
DECADES.
YOU MENTIONED RYAN.
WE KNOW KOREN ONE OF THE TOP
REPUBLICANS SAID WE MAY HAVE
HEARINGS ON THIS.
WE HAVE OVERSIGHT FROM THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH ON THESE
ISSUES.
ASHLEIGH STRONG SAYING WE'RE
EXTREMELY WORRIED ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF A TRADE WAR AND
ARE URGING THE WHITE HOUSE TO
NOT ADVANCE WITH THIS PLAN.
HERE'S THE RESPONSE.
>> WE HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH SPEAKER RYAN.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE ONE BUT
WE DON'T HAVE TO AGREE ON
EVERYTHING.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THIS IS AN AREA WHERE TRUMP
DEVIATES FROM ORTHODOXY.
THE FIRST YEAR WAS A YEAR MARKED
BY FREE ECONOMICS.
YOU HAD TAX CUTS AND BROAD
DEREGULATION AND NOW YOU HAVE
THE OPPOSITE.
YOU HAVE AN INCREASE IN
SPENDING.
PLANS TO INCREASE EVEN MORE.
AND NOW A BELIEF THAT
REGULATION, NOT DEREGULATION IS
NOT GOOD FOR INTERNATIONAL
MARKETS.
YOU SAW THE STOCK MARKET DO
WELL.
30 PERCENT INCREASE IN THE FIRST
YEAR.
RECENTLY YOU SAW A 6 PERCENT
DECREASE IN THE STOCK MARKET.
NOT TO SAY THE ONLY THING THAT
MATTERS IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
TRUMP IS CONSISTENT HE THINKS
THIS IS PART OF A LARGER
PHILOSOPHY THAT HE NEEDS TO SHOW
STRENGTH.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE MARKET WILL
ALLOW THAT.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE?
THE MARKET ALL OVER THE PLACE
SINCE THIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS TWEETING
ABOUT OTHER INDICATORS, HE FOUND
OTHER FAVORITES.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
HAVE THE LAST WORD.
CONGRESS CAN HAVE HEARINGS AND
WORRIED AS THEY WANT TO BE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SAYING
SINCE HE WAS ELECTED.
LITERALLY HE WOULD SAY, BRING ME
TARIFFS AND OVER THE WEEKEND,
REPORTING FROM SWAN SAYING THERE
WAS A SHOWDOWN IN JANUARY IN THE
OVAL OFFICE WHERE THE PRESIDENT
HAD -- HAD -- THEY FIGHT IT OUT.
GARY KOEN FOR THE FREE TRADE AND
THE COMMERCE SECRETARY WILBUR
ROSS ON THE OTHER SIDE.
THE PRESIDENT CALLED GARY KOEN
[INDISCERNIBLE] IN FRONT OF
OTHERS.
KOEN MOVES OVER TO A COUCH IN
THE OVAL OFFICE AND HIM MOVING
OVER, THAT'S WHEN THIS WAS
REALLY SETTLED.
THE PRESIDENT KNEW HE WAS GOING
TO GET WHAT HE WAS SAYING.
HE WAS GOING TO GET TARIFFS.
>> CONGRESS HAS AUTHORITY HERE.
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS THIS
SHOULD BE SET BY CONGRESS AND
ANY TARIFF OR THING LIKE THIS.
THE PRESIDENT WAS APPEALING TO
NATIONAL SECURITY CONCERNS,
SAYING YOU NEED FACTORIES AND
STEEL RESOURCES OUT OF NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERNS.
NOT LIKE THERE'S NOT AN ARGUMENT
FOR THAT BUT THE LAW LETS YOU
ENACT TARIFFS.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT FOR AN END
RUN.
>> YOU SAW HOW THAT WENT OVER
WITH CANADA.
ONE OF OUR BEST ALLIES.  FOR HIM
TO INVOKE IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE, ESPECIALLY IN
CANADA AND OTHER PLACES.
>> NOT GOING WELL AROUND THE
GLOBE.
IF TRUMP USES THIS AS
NEGOTIATING TACTIC, IT
UNDERMINES THE ARGUMENT THAT HE
WAS A NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT
TO BEGIN WITH.
>> IT IS ALSO TRUE THAT THE
U.S. HAS LOWER TARIFFS THAN
EVERYBODY ELSE.
FOR PEOPLE TO ACT LIKE THIS IS,
IF IT IS UNACCEPTABLE FOR US, IT
IS UNACCEPTABLE FOR OTHER
COUNTRIES.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO
ANYTHING THEY WANT.
THE TARIFFS ARE A TAX ON PEOPLE
AND THEY'RE NOT GENERALLY A GOOD
IDEA.
>> I THOUGHT THERE WOULD BE
MORE CUT-OUTS THAN THERE WERE
AND CANADA AND EUROPE AND NOW
INDIVIDUAL COMPANIES, COULD YOU
IMAGINE, THAT'S LIKE WAVING A
RED CAPE OVER HERE.
THAT'S A LOBBYING FREE FALL.
>> AND THIS IDEA WHETHER IT IS
NEGOTIATING THE PRESIDENT IS
TALKING ABOUT THIS IN TERMS OF
NAFTA NEGOTIATIONS.
HE HAD A THREE-PARTY TWEET.
HE SAID WE HAVE LARGE TRADE DEBT
WITH CANADA AND MEXICO, AND
NAFTA WHICH IS UNDER
RENEGOTIATION HAS BEEN A BAD
DEAL FOR USA, MASSIVE RELOCATION